the last time i saw you didn't have any
jewelry on you got the
you got the [ __ ] grill you got the
watches how how recent did you get this
watch all this [ __ ] is new
um i'm getting my man emotional easy bro
just saying he's proud of me
what kind of watch is that uh she's got
a rolex ap
oh it's an ap i don't know
it seems it seems to be kind of uh
gaudy for your nature who i would say
like like yeah
it feel weird does it feel weird to be
walking around with someone's like
like you know bentley on your wrist this
is
i don't know i don't know honestly no
nick it was a guy how much is the watch
tony
50k that's a that's a like a it's a
great kia minivan like fully loaded
50k man you know they got it's a nice
watch
you got that that was gifted to you yes
i'm saying like all this [ __ ] like no
cam
like mo no that's not me right so he
like yo bro just
i'll get it for you then [ __ ] it you
flex one time but i ain't a [ __ ]
i'm a big relaxer fifty thousand hey
[ __ ] come hey worst comes the worst
sell that [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying oh god where's
she hits the face you said the number i
said i wonder how much i can get for no
[ __ ]
i ain't going to god [ __ ] [ __ ] like
that i gotta fight marie ward maybe i'll
say 75.
i don't [ __ ] know you oh god